o trabalho de quique que faz vídeos que
o argumento contra o mal isto por falar
em telemóveis muitos anos podem
implantar no brasil alguns e de vocês
quais é que já partilharam esses vídeos
na internet em sites como youtube
facebook vai - ainda ok eu sou daniel
brandão
eu estou aqui hoje como os outros
jogadores para falar sobre a minha mãe
tinga
enfim é um projeto que adotou uma forma
simbólica e metafórica os nomes os
conceitos do museu e do fígado
isto porque não é propriamente um museu
e não tem a função propriamente de
recuperar e restaurar vídeos antigos da
cidade
antes mais é um website que tem como
principal objetivo pôr as pessoas os
cidadãos do porto a fazer vídeos sobre o
seu cotidiano
pensando qual o seu valor cultural e
identitário e de alguma forma também
pensar sobre por que estão a fazer estes
vídeos e eu comece então para os
aposentados com um cheiro é legal pra
mim o digital é algo que está cada vez
mais presente no nosso cotidiano nosso
dia a dia e tem alterado de forma
profunda a forma como comunicamos uns
com os outros
o registo de imagens de fotografia como
vídeo tem se tornado cada vez mais
pequenas mais baratas mais fáceis de
transportar mais fáceis de utilizar de
cada vez menos do torcedor comum e
websites para publicação partilha de
vídeos gratuitos na internet como o
youtube
o vine está agora muito na moda também
alterar a forma como consumimos
conteúdos audiovisuais
agora cada vez mais centrados em
conteúdos amadores ou seja profissionais
aqui uma alternativa aquilo que a
própria televisão e por falar em
amadores diferentes modos perante estas
ferramentas e as contas têm surgido
temos desde os amadores mais sérios mais
profissionais digamos assim que chegaram
nas suas câmeras dslr pretendem fazer
fotografia o vídeo seguinte terminar de
tutoriais na internet para atingir um
determinado ano determinada qualidade
estética e temos do outro lado ana dos
do cotidiano dos seus telemóveis apenas
para registar imagens para mais tarde os
culpados e paralelamente a isto e aquilo
que é produzido pelos cidadãos têm vindo
a ser conhecido enquanto património
cultural por instituições
de uma forma ou num processo os pais
cidadãos têm vindo a ser excluídos tanta
pergunta que em estudos
é precisamente esta moda então é que
este valor o valor identidade cultural
dos vídeos caseiros que nós todos
produzidos com tamanha maldade pode soar
em termos culturais nos parâmetros
documentário contemporâneo ou seja nada
que nós podemos então conhecer neste
vídeo que vocês fazem os telemóveis qual
o seu valor cultural e patrimonial
temos algumas gatas que tem precisa
responder esta esta questão o apoio
principal
para isso o programa novas no porto foi
um programa que em dois anos 2011 2012
com fundos comunitários pretendeu agitar
cultural - aquilo que é o centro
histórico do porto também estamos a
falar de uma zona que é património da
própria unesco e todo este ambiente
fértil a participação em um programa do
canal do porto no profissional eu foi o
ideal para que então este projecto fizer
sentido e tivesse o sucesso está ligado
à investigação foi adotada aqui uma
antologia de investigação de uma forma
muito intuitiva ali anos é prática a
pensamento crítico e produção do
conhecimento
numa primeira fase
vencemos o território vamos falar com as
pessoas prevê quais as problemáticas que
se passava no centro histórico do forno
com muitas pessoas utilizavam essas
ferramentas digitais é o visual e também
identificar outros estudantes que
estavam no fundo desenvolvidos na zona
tivemos que definir então um nome para o
projeto e desenhar um motivo e explodem
pra mim é muito importante porque
simbolicamente tem duas funções a
primeira junta as duas iniciais do
próprio projecto e ao mesmo tempo coloca
uma forma também simbólica e figurativa
dois rostos frente a frente numa
tentativa de comunicado com
e seguindo desenvolvemos então website
que inicialmente se dividia em três
grandes áreas dois anos sempre uma
linguagem muito direta e muito
aproximada ao público alvo em questão
na primeira área o que é mais comum no
fundo conta isto também muito direto e
muito assim não área do que isto
explicou brevemente sobre o projeto
depois temos uma área do passa pra cá os
vídeos em que as pessoas se mantêm os
seus vídeos através de um formulário
onde podem agregar campanha informação
como o título à data o nome do autor ou
até mesmo então posição geográfica onde
foi registado o próprio vire e depois
temos uma área do euro que já cá cantam
quando vocês podem ver os mais de 200
vídeos em bruto somou licença creative
commons instante podem ser utilizados em
utilizar de quantas vezes quiserem sem
fins comerciais e podem ser visionadas
diretamente no website sabe estar em
todos os jogos no youtube podem ser
visionadas em braga ou então em formato
do mapa com o posição geográfica de cada
um destes vídeos numa quarta área que
surgiu a estrela - e que agora está
ainda em desenvolvimento
pretendemos seja uma área aberta à
interpretação no fundo a reflexão sobre
toda esta quinta
ou seja quase 1.100 salas de exposição
sobre o sobre a área do museu mas não
podemos ficar fãs do website
temos que passar à ação de falar com as
pessoas no terreno comunicar com elas e
divulgar o projeto executado contribuído
os locais aos quais distribuímos câmeras
de vídeo para regularmente e recolhendo
vídeos organizarmos cujos sinais através
do dri várias pessoas aos sábados andré
varão pela pelo centro histórico e no
final sobre um vídeo seu próprio projeto
tivemos no final das sessões do já
estamos em evolução dos resultados a
comunidade através de lixo box que era
um fundo e projeções interativas
todos podiam escolher os vídeos que
estavam lesionados em estabelecimentos
locais no centro histórico desses
resultados é interessante pra que em
duas freguesias que tiveram uma média de
duração vídeos mais baixa ter
relacionado com o facto de participantes
nesta freguesia ano teve um fraco ainda
conhecido no fundo relação com a
ferramenta do vídeo para fazer um vídeo
com quem faz uma fotografia
curioso é perceber também que wu na
evolução do projecto esta duração foi
também evoluindo e aumentando também o
outro fato curioso esse diferencial nos
foram de vídeos que foram obtidos nas
duas freguesias da cet são igual tanto
mais do dobro seguida seque por norma
entre por muitos como uma freguesia e
tem problemas em termos de segurança na
via pública e fred sonic 4 ea franquia
pintura queria proporcionar a partir da
mãe maior quantidade de filhos até que
um jogador profissional né é uma visão
alternativa sobre a própria cidade e
traga o tamanho do episódio em que teve
a ver com o trabalho no terreno e que no
fundo todos que é o trabalho no gráfico
tem a ver com o roubo de uma câmara de
filmar precisamente no último dia em que
tivermos a trabalhar tanto eu trago aqui
um instinto da câmera que foi filmado na
partida - e outro 1 enquanto fugia com a
perna e nós o que vence convence anos
no fundo a devolver a câmera ela foi
quase no fundo minha vida em um mercado
negro e trazia os próprios vídeos que eu
nem sabia que tinha filmado
o melhor vai lá e reage porque tu ó ó
nunca alguém vai lá uma joão foi o
caminho da europa gemma e totó ninguém
arranja um jeito ninguém nem com ninguém
a brecha política ao reboque como errada
verba foi gasta já achou um colega que o
guardiola vem mais tranqüilo é que
alguém vai lá que em meu deus olha vou
ter de ralar mesmo palavra luan e para
treinar em conclusão é que os gatos
acabou por proporcionar foi uma
aprendizagem sobre as ferramentas do
registro audiovisual através de e mails
a proporcionar câmeras de vídeo e
através de incentivos ou seja a razão
para parar no fundo contribuir para uma
visão múltipla sobre a cidade e através
das oportunidades das ações que estão
sendo participativas no terreno e temos
então uma diversidade uma diversidade em
contraponto a uma visão única sobre a
própria cidade
em resposta à pergunta a pergunta
inicial
acreditamos que este valor patrimonial o
valor cultural dos vídeos que nós todos
fazemos pode ser conhecida através de
conquistar isso participativo de
inclusão e não através de um processo em
que está sendo atualmente desenvolvido
uma forma internacional e esta última
imagem no fundo atrás de uma forma
simbólica por exemplo daquilo que sou a
forma com consoles projeto cachorro
brasil à espera de ser preenchido e da
forma como eu e atualmente está também à
espera de ser também impresso com vossa
participação por isso convidamos a
visitar o website www quanto nos outros
gado quanto óleo e estarem mais
informada sobre este projeto
obrigado